this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies in the previous video we
learned what electric charge really was
a measure of how much something can
affect the electric field so the next
logical question is does the magnetic
field work the same way is there some
kind of magnetic charge that affects the
magnetic field that would be nice but
it's it's a little more complicated than
that
no the magnetic field is affected by the
same thing as the electric field
electric charge this proton has a
positive electric charge if it's sitting
still then only the electric field is
affected but if it moves it can also
affect the magnetic field the orange X's
and dots represent Direction into and
out of your screen because that's what a
simple arrow would look like in each of
those cases we can see the moving proton
affects both fields historically though
we don't do experiments with single
charged particles so while this diagram
is accurate it's not very practical we
usually have a bunch of charges moving
together in something we call a current
to the time line in 1819 Hans Christian
Oersted noticed that magnetic compasses
deflected near a current carrying wire
kind of like this I'm off I'm off I'm
off then in 1820 Jones empties Bo and
Felix Savar found a simple pattern for
this but then pierre-simon Laplace
almost immediately generalized it
because you know mathematicians were
like that
sidenote Laplace was a bamf seriously he
was like 70 by the time he did this to
honor Laplace for his hard work we named
his law Laplace's law just kidding it's
called the biot-savart law what his name
isn't even on it yes I know it totally
sucks but in all fairness the man has
plenty of stuff named after him he
doesn't really need it even
electrodynamics the topic of this series
has a Laplace's equation he did a lot of
stuff in his life and of sidenote the
point is magnetism appears when charge
moves it doesn't matter if it's a single
charge or a whole bunch of charges
moving through a long wire
it doesn't even matter how the wire is
shaped moving charge affects the
magnetic field sure that's true for
electromagnet but that doesn't really
explain yes are you really gonna make me
go there yes you crazy you're gonna like
it
okay I can do this we have what seems to
be two different kinds of magnets an
electromagnet and what we call a
permanent magnets but in the end we'll
see that both types of magnets are
really caused by the same thing let's
start with the names an electromagnet
is a magnet created by electricity there
isn't any electric current running
through a magnet like this though so it
seemed like it should go by a different
name we went with permanent magnet
because we thought they lasted forever
over time though they can lose their
magnetism especially if they get hot but
left to their own devices that process
could easily take thousands of years
compared to a human lifespan that still
seems like forever anyway it's the name
we're stuck with now for the basic
properties based on the shape of the
magnetic field we noticed there are two
opposite sources we call those sources
poles and label them north and south why
we use those labels has to do with
Earth's magnetic field but but that's a
topic for another day all permanent
magnets have at least one North Pole and
one South Pole even electromagnets have
poles if they're shaped certain ways
sometimes magnets have more than one set
of poles but they always come in pairs
always it's a behavior summed up pretty
well with Gauss's law for magnetism so
how is a piece of material magnetic if
there's no electric current quantum
mechanics pull onto your bus do you
understand how something like this can
be a magnet we need to look closer a lot
closer sofa zoom this is what a chunk of
iron looks like on a molecular level yet
we still don't see any moving charges
for that we have to zoom in one more
step this cloud of negative charge is
made of 26 electrons each of those
electrons is in something called an
orbital those come in a variety of
shapes each with a set of available
properties but we need to be careful
quantum particles can have all sorts of
properties position energy
linear momentum angular momentum all the
properties the property the electrons
have in these orbitals is angular
momentum in fact we can measure both the
total amount and the orientation at
least along one direction just having
that property is enough to make it a
tiny magnet any electron with a non zero
angular momentum will act like a tiny
magnet unfortunately that doesn't
necessarily turn the entire iron atom
into a magnet because electrons tend to
pair up in opposite directions
there are 26 electrons in an iron atom
for each one that's in a clockwise
orbital there's another one that's in a
counterclockwise orbital they cancel
each other out so this level of
existence isn't deep enough we need to
zoom in even closer this single electron
has an inherent property called spin
angular momentum that's something we
talked a lot about in this video it's
not really a motion but it is momentum
and that's enough for magnetism when you
zoom back out to the atomic level most
of those electrons still pair up and
cancel except for of them because like
charges repel they get as far from each
other as possible and line up in the
same direction at least an iron the more
of those loner electrons and atom has
lined up the more magnetic it's going to
be that tends to happen in the middle of
blocks on the periodic table
but just because an atom is magnetic it
doesn't necessarily mean the material is
magnetic don't ever jump to conclusions
in quantum mechanics getting the loner
electrons to line up isn't enough you
also have to get nearby atoms to line up
with each other and then get enough
regions of atoms to line up we call
those regions domains the point is
magnetic materials are hard to come by
in fact there are only four elements
that do this at room temperature iron
cobalt nickel and gadolinium beyond that
we either need to get the material
really cold or build the material using
a specially designed molecule or both so
what the heck is a magnet magnets are
what you get when charges move or
least have momentum that's true if
you're talking about a single charge a
bunch of charges and a current or even
the spin of subatomic charges in a piece
of iron all magnets come from charges so
all magnets are electromagnets wicked
huh
so how fascinated are you by magnets let
us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and it's till next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video a big question was why
do particles have the specific charges
that they do well we don't know those
charges have to be measured and then put
into the standard model we haven't found
an underlying mechanism yet anyway
thanks for watching
[Music]